Before we say goodbye, let's play a quick round of
Drewth or Dare.
(audience applauds)
We have Sylvia Hooper.
Hi, Sylvia.
Hi.
Okay, it's all about your leopard belt.
Look at this.
I was noticing the nails.
Hey.
All right, what's it gonna be, a drewth or a dare?
Drewth.
Okay, hit us.
So, in honor
of International Women's Day,
we're gonna talk about our biggest female inspiration.
And so for me, mine is my mom, Gwendolyn Hooper.
She was a foster parent, fostered many children,
and adopted my brother and I,
and instilled in us the values of education,
hard work, and determination.
And so wanna know who your biggest inspiration is?
Aw.
I think I know who Ross might pick.
Yeah, I'm with you, I'm a mama's boy all the way.
And my mom was just
(audience applauds)
so filled with that sort of goodness
and that heart that it sounds like your mom has, as well.
And there's something that just,
there's no love like the love from a good mama, right, yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you for asking.
What about you?
My girls.
Aw.
(audience applauds)
Well, thank you, Sylvia.
Thank you both.
Thank you so much
and we celebrate your mom today and we always celebrate
your mom, Rossy, here at the show.
Thank you.
She is
a permanent fixture in our hearts.
Aw, gosh, oh.
It's true.
Thank you, thank you.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
Thank you everybody.
(upbeat music)